[Music]
i'd like to bring in andrew adonis now
level pierre romero vocal campaigner at
one stage for a second referendum and an
even more
vocal critic of the johnson government
andrew adonis welcome to spectator
tv uh as i say you've been
very critical at all sorts of things of
the johnson government
but when you look at what it stands for
more money on infrastructure
revitalizing the north
hs2 leading on climate change
that will reads like an android adonis
manifesto
everything you've just said andrew i
agree with and i've always taken the
view you know i'm
one of life's natural um bridge builders
uh
across the political divide and uh where
i agree i always say i agree
i've strongly support what boys johnson
has been doing
in terms of a serious infrastructure
strategy of the country i don't agree
with all his things i think the idea of
a bridge or a tunnel
under or over the irish sea isn't viable
and uh the much bigger priorities than
that but his
own union he's a huge part of the
johnson government's program
billions of pounds being devoted to them
yeah i agree with all i agree with why
are you not a bit more supportive
like like your old mate tony blair he
seems to be advising the government
all the time he seems to want you know
he criticizes it too because he's got
differences like yourself
but he seems to want to work with it why
why don't you take a
page out the blair book well i i have
been very strongly
supportive on hs2 i can assure you every
time these big infrastructure schemes
come before
the house of lords i speak strongly and
support them and i've been voting with
the government on them so
where i agree with the government i say
so and indeed listening to your program
earlier i agree with what you've been
saying about the vaccine as well
i think kate bingham the nhs under the
leadership of the government have done a
good job
on the vaccine rollout they played did
absolutely the right thing
in negotiating early and robustly
in terms of vaccine contracts they
rightly understood this was a war
situation where you just have to pay
what it takes
and uh and just get on with it in a
really serious way
and the eu has handled the vaccine
rollout both the
procurement uh issue and also the
rollout itself
very badly i mean let's be completely
open with this i've never regarded
politics as
a business of saying that black is white
and white is black what we've now got to
do is to find a way through this
together and what i'm
relieved to see happening this week as
if i read the runes correctly
is that we're not going to engage in
vaccine battles between britain and the
eu i think for the eu to have an export
ban in respect to britain
or britain to seek to worst the eu
would be a really really big mistake for
both of us and it does sound as if
president macron chancellor merkel and
and prime minister boris johnson
have reached an understanding that we're
going to seek to maximize
production across britain and europe for
the vaccine which is the right response
and not to engage either in bands or in
tit for tat action
all right well i'll chop that up as
another issue in which you and the
government
align um but you wanted britain to join
the eu
procurement program you didn't want
britain to go its own way
no i i never wanted britain to join the
eu procurement program that's incorrect
it's true that some of my colleagues did
my own view is that it was a mistake for
the eu to seek to become a health union
and i said that a year ago
i never i've never called to britain to
be part of the eu
um you criticize the government for
going it alone
no i haven't that's that's that's
incorrect andrew i mean you need to
examine the record
i never said that we should be part of
the eu procurement program my own view
was that it was correct in this very
fast-moving crisis
where the people who best understood the
industrial production
mechanisms and uh potential sources of
production
we're going to be the member states
because they're the ones who know these
companies best
and are closest to them and my own view
if i've been in government a year ago
is that we should have opted out of any
eu uh procurement program which we had
the powers to do
so on that one i'm glad to say i've been
consistent all the way through
oh hold on hold on you said that the
british vaccine roll
out would lead to billions of corrupt
contracts and the supply and
distribution would be
a fiasco no that's not correct
well it is i've got the tweet here on
november the the
the 11th you tweeted out it now looks as
if the vaccine is going to lead to
billions of corrupt contracts
and jobs for friends and relations of
ministers
like ppe and test and trade making
supply
and distribution of fiasco too these are
your words
no i was i was talking about all of the
ppe and all of the contracts which we
knew about then
no it now looks as if the vaccine is
going to lead to
billions of corrupt contracts i would
have
i would have i've done a a direct
procurement
i i would have done an efficient direct
procurement it
it inspires i thought this government
wasn't capable of negotiating
uh efficiently
kate bingham has clearly done a good job
so and i i i pay full respect to that
but you attacked the health secretary
i never let let's be clear andrew i
never said that we should be part
of the health secretary's claims about a
speedy rollout were quote
never said that we should be sorry i'm
answering your earlier question and
you're putting a different point
i've moved on i never said i never said
that we should be part
of the eu vaccine procurement it was
always my view
this should be done at nation state
level it was my view you're right and
you've just quoted the
tweets that i didn't think that this
government would be capable
of doing a highly efficient
vaccine procurement they have done a
highly efficient vaccine procurement
and i pay tribute to that and that's
absolutely the right thing we need for
the country but it was never my view
that the eu should become a health union
it wasn't my view then and it isn't my
view now
no but well even if you did support as i
say even if you supported that britain
should be doing the procurement on its
own
and not going down the eu eu you did say
it would lead to corrupt contracts
supply and distribution would be a
fiasco and
that the health secrecy's claims about a
speedy rollout were quote pitiful now
these were your
would you like to apologize to the
health secretary now
i i was wrong about that the nhs has
done a brilliant job
i absolutely pay tribute to nhs and to
matt hancock for the work that's been
done in the vaccine procurement
uh i think it was fair to say at the
time though when you looked at how the
whole of the
procurement contracts for ppe and all of
the
earlier stages the crisis were concerned
it was perfectly reasonable at the time
to think that
it wouldn't be well handled the reason
why i think it's
important to understand that i think why
it was well handled andrew two things
happened
the first was a serious expert was
secured in
biotech procurement in kate bingham
uh so we didn't go just somebody who you
know had run a mobile
phone network and thought they would
have transferable skills
for uh vaccines but the second thing was
the rollout was done
by simon stevens and the nhs using their
established
processes including the fact of course
that virtually the entire population has
signed up to a gp surgery under the nhs
so looking back at what happened the
government made one very sensible
decision which was to get a serious
biotech
expert in to do the procurement of the
vaccine and then it relied for its
distribution on the nhs
those were two very good decisions they
were radically different from what had
gone before
and they learned the correct lessons
indeed and you would have been justified
in calling
what had gone before a fiasco or pitiful
but
not the the vaccine rollout which you
did but you've now
you've now clarified that and you're
right you have been very critical of the
european union or european commission's
handling
of its vaccine roll out and particularly
of the president of the commission
russell uh van der leyen
uh you even called her the theresa may
of european politics
uh but when the british i didn't want to
be outdone by you andrew
in my description sorry i missed that
say that again i i didn't want to be
outdone by you in my description of her
because i knew i was coming on your
pokemon
that's exactly regarded as normal as
hard to be more damning but when
the british people and then the tory
party quickly rumbled that theresa may
was a dud
um they got rid of her how does the
how do eu citizens get rid of ursula van
der layne
well let's be clear it wasn't british
citizens who got rid of treasure made
was the conservative party no i didn't
say that
but they did that because they realized
that she was going down
badly with the british public so they
got rid of her how do you do the same
with the president of the commission
well the european leaders and the
european parliament do have powers to
replace the commission
uh 20 years ago they did replace the
president of the commissioner do you
remember a guy called jack santer
who was uh incapable of leading the
european commission properly and they
got rid of him fairly quickly
i don't know that we're at that stage
yet because if you look at what's
happened on europe there have been two
big
sets of of uh mistakes the first was the
failure to get on top of procurement
very rapidly
that was mistake one mistake two was
with the member states it was a huge
mistake of president macron and
chancellor merkel
to raise doubts over the efficacy of the
vaccine
that wasn't the commission's fault that
was the leaders of france and germany
so and so what they've got to do is to
un unwind both of those mistakes they've
got to make absolutely clear that these
vaccines are safe so that the uptake
increases amongst people who could take
it but aren't at the moment
and secondly they've got to get supply
in place now
these are huge challenges for them over
the next few months if they succeed then
i don't think there'll be
such big demands for change of
leadership if they were to fail then i
think
calls for a change of leadership at the
commission will become very loud indeed
but despite the difficulties i put it no
higher than that that the european
commission has faced in its vaccine
rollout we now have senior eu
politicians like the president
of the european parliament
saying as they often do in these
circumstances the answer is not
less europe it's more europe he says we
need to develop a
european health policy more europe
not less i don't think that's going to
be the view of most
eu members after this i don't think it's
going to be their view that the eu
should become a health union
but it's important to understand what
we're dealing with is is a
a serious very very serious one-off
crisis i don't think either you or i
expect that we're going to be going
from pandemic to pandemic so every
country has had to develop
emergency arrangements for dealing with
the pandemic
including how you procure vaccines how
you roll them out and so on
i don't think that anyone looking at a
pandemic after this would think it's a
great idea to put the european
commission
in charge of the procurement of a wholly
new form of industrial production
which depends crucially on on local
production and local distribution so be
surprised if any sensible political
leader in europe would think that the
answer to the problems of this pandemic
is to repeat the same mistakes in a
future one but
hopefully we're not going to be dealing
with uh future people on this scale
regard david uh as the president of the
eu parliament as a
sensible politician you may not agree
with him but he's sensible
and we've been here before haven't we
when
europe or people like the president of
the eu parliament say
we need to get europe needs to get more
stuck into this or that or whatever
important policies people like you say
oh no no no europe isn't
ever going to go there that's not going
to happen and it does
it does end up going there well that's
the well you need to separate
going down the health route yeah we need
to separate out different things
when it's come to closer economic
coordination
and integration the eu has advanced and
i have supported that
i'm a strong supporter as was margaret
thatcher of the single market
of removing trade and tariff barriers
including non-tariff barriers in terms
of the recognition of qualifications
people being able to move and so on
so we create a much much stronger
european market
i supported that at the time i support
that retrospectively i think it was a
huge
mistake for britain to leave the single
market in the customs unit it is my view
andrew that we will end up going back
into them again
because we will pay such a big economic
price price
for not being part of the european
market i don't believe that the same
arguments apply
when it comes to the running of health
systems i think health systems are
inherently national and indeed often
local if you go to germany the health
systems are different between
the 16 german states so i don't think
the same arguments apply i
i believe that good judgment in politics
makes means being able to differentiate
between ideas that are good in one
context and bad in another it's a good
idea to have european collaboration and
partnership when it comes to deepening
markets
and trade it's a bad idea to be trying
to create one health system
across 28 countries
but speaking of good judgment you said
in october 2019 that john berko was a
natural candidate to lead a government
of national unity
can we are we really going to file that
under good judgment
uh i think we should have had a
government of national unity in october
29th
john burko dominic grieve david
livington
any of these people would have been a
huge improvement on boris johnson
leading us into the hard brexit we've
got which is going to work for which
we're going to play an absolutely
massive
economic price i think the majority of
people would have supported
your your idea of good political
judgment
is that john burko should have led a
government of national unity in
in october 2019 for the purpose of
holding
for the purpose of holding a second
referendum that would then have led
to a general election which obviously
the leader of that government of
national unity wouldn't have uh
have been a part of because we would
have reverted to normal party politics i
think that would have been a very very
great improvement on what happened
which was hurtling into a hard brexit
leaving the european customs union
leaving the single markets
40 percent drop in trade andrew by the
official ons statistics
in in january i think that's what that
is
and you know the hard drives that
happened you know there was massive
stockpiling in december
let's see what it's like by the end of
this month and we'll have a
proper feel for what's actually
happening well any reduction
i mean you're a free trader andrew you
know let's let's be frank about things
where we agree
any reduction in british trade with the
continent don't need to be 40
if it was four percent that would be a
huge economic price that we'd be paying
you're right that's one month figures
those were really really terrible
one-month figures though
things have got to be absolutely
transformed
very rapidly if we're not going to pay a
big price
in trade in jobs and in people's incomes
for the hard brexit which
unfortunately boris johnson's forced us
into just to bring us back finally to
uh the matter that's in dispute uh
this week it is your judgment i think
you were saying
that the eu and the uk will pull back
from the brink and what's been called
vaccine nationalism
that they will come to a working
arrangement is that correct
well fortunately we've got chancellor
merkel
whose judgment is always pretty good on
these things and she does appear to be
steering the commission
very hard against export bans and
so provided her wise councils continue
to prevail
it looks as if we'll concentrate on what
we should be concentrating on which is
maximizing production between us
and not a zero-sum game of uh of trying
to ban exports between us
all right uh android honors thanks uh
for being on
spectator tv be a pleasure to see you
coming into
the spectator offices today thank you
for that
[Music]
you